[Musik]
burg schauspielerin birte schneider
liest ausgewählte hass kommentare
[Musik]
guten abend dank master schreibt auf
twitter euch vollidioten ist wohl jedes
mittel recht um aufmerksamkeit zu
erregen
trump sollte mal die raketen auf euer
studio lenken
mal sehen ob er danach eure dämliche
zoten noch reißen könnte ja sie kleine
frechdachs selbstverständlich würden wir
nach einem raketenangriff von trump
keine witze mehr reißen
immerhin wäre dann ja der achtung erste
weltkrieg musste einfach sein
moment mal
moment mal raketen auf unser studio mehr
aufmerksamkeit geht ja gar nicht und sie
wissen uns ist da für jedes mittel recht
bussi und guten rutsch peter b schreibt
auf facebook witz komm raus bist
umzingelt täglich mehrfach dünnschiss
vom zdf zeigt damit arschlöcher
gebührenzahler bekommen für jeden furz
mehr als ein mindestlöhne die ganze
woche ja wie soll ich sagen diese diese
dünnschiss tabletten sind eben sehr
teuer und außerdem brauchen wir die
erlesensten weine um unseren
flüssigkeitshaushalt wieder herzustellen
lieben gruß
[Musik]
ja
danny s schreibt auf youtube oliver
welke ist der letzte mensch der morgens
in den spiegel schauen kann ohne sich
ununterbrochen voll zu kotzen und aus
selbst kam ein zu scheißen bleibt mir
ein rätsel ihnen mag es ein rätsel sein
herr es aber was meinen sie was es für
uns ist hier arbeitet ein zwölfköpfiges
team aus reinigungskräften visagisten
und kostümbildnern daran in welcher
abzuwickeln zu desinfizieren zu bruder
neu einzukleiden und ihm ein
menschliches gesicht zu schminken
bevor er das studio betritt das ist
verdammt harte arbeit aber was bleibt
uns anderes übrig
[Musik]
zuletzt schreibblock pharma auf youtube
welke ist ein erbärmlicher system
stricher mit dem manischen drang seine
regime treue zu beweisen indem er sich
unermüdlich für die alternativlosigkeit
prostituierte denn das garantiert ihm
den drop und das fette durch die ez
schutzgeld eingetriebene einkommen liebe
plattform wir können sie beruhigen von
ihrem eingetriebenen gez schutzgeld geht
nichts in das einkommen von oli welche
viel mehr zahlen wir davon kaviar
trüffel und champagner für unser zweites
redaktions frühstück um 15 30 die hälfte
werfen wir natürlich weg wir wollen ja
nicht dass unsere mindestlohn masseure
und die palmen wedler heimlich davon
naschen
also wäre verschwendung ich bedanke mich
vielmals für ihre konstruktive kritik
die sie uns im jahre 2018 haben zukommen
lassen
wir freuen uns auf die zusammenarbeit im
nächsten jahr
[Musik]